amici bellissimi e un momento di
nostalgia per me al momento di nostalgia
perché allora avevo già parlato di
questa cosa io conobbi youtube il magico
mondo del tubo nel 2006 2000 e 2600 più
o meno 2016 del 7 e mi iscrissi a
youtube nel 2007 il mio primo canale fu
lori 600 56 che non è il pin della mia
carta di credito non tentate di fottermi
quando ti iscrivi un sito
io volevo chiamarmi lori lori e mi sono
scritto youtube come ti chiami i lori
lory non è disponibile però volendo puoi
usare lori 6005 sei una persona normale
ovviamente quello che dice no vabbè ma
che schifo chiamiamoci giovanni pinotti
no va bene loris e 0056 andata al link
nei più bello del mondo è più lungo il
numero del nome ma chi se ne frega e
crea i lori 600 56 che è questo canale
che attualmente a 7.300 iscritti però
molti di questi sono fan che lo sapevano
e quindi sono a rischio che in realtà
lavora giunti sui 3000 4000 è si è
salvato solo un video che hardest game
ever che praticamente un video dove
vabbè faccio una cosa su un gioco
difficile va bene perchè gli ho fatto
tutta questa pappardella che non ve ne
frega una mazza perché i primissimi
video che ho visualizzato volevo
condividerli con voi adesso è una cosa
che avevo fatto però male volevo farla
far vedere i primi video i propri primi
video che io ho visto su youtube con i
quali ho conosciuto questa piattaforma
con i quali mi sono innamorato del web
andiamo a vederli questo è il primissimo
video in assoluto che ho visto su
youtube
ai bambini io vorrei comm
[Musica]
mamma mia
onde evitare che mi mettano il copyright
poi per una roba veramente che mi chiedo
il perché io nel 2000 questo nel video
del 6 marzo 2006 2006 è uscito io l'ho
visto quasi subito e nel 2006 avevo 11
anni se la matematica non è un'opinione
e a 11 anni ho visto questo lasca fori e
da lì ho deciso di fare lo youtube non è
vero comunque non ho iniziato a farlo di
tuber nel 2006 ma nel 2011 ne vedo dice
all'inizio facevo vide un po facevo cag
arte ero bella gente vi faccio vedere
sempre che cos'è che mi ha formato nei
miei primi anni youtube e non credo che
voi siete pronti c'era una canzone è che
si chiamava per chi non la conoscesse
friday io ho ascoltato questa canzone
per quanto rebecca sia diventata una
bravissima youtuber tra l'altro non so
se lo sapete non so se me ne frega una
mazza non so niente della vostra vita
mettete mi piace al video mio non voglio
dire perché però c'era un video di
friday che mi piaceva un sacco e questa
estate è stato veramente uno dei primi
video oltre quello di prima che è questo
di profit a sanremo nei carabi fresca
sarà mai poca c'è il grido lui doppia
doppia va adesso non sono più una faccia
di unire doppiava che se nel 2011 poi ha
iniziato a fare proprio youtuber pensate
che lui doppiava le canzoni ed era
bellissima questa cosa prima di adesso
basta mai bas sii my friends
perché non si pestano questo era
diventato un meme bellissimo my hand
isadora per questa fascia la musica la
mano
va beh queste brooks dub e tra l'altro
el altro video che guarda un po ragazzi
brox tab è la storia cioè io non so come
sia possibile che non sia diventato
presidente ma vabbè comunque questa era
il mio inizio su youtube ho iniziato a
guardare questi video uno dei primi
video mi ricordo anche che che vidi e i
tempi e tra l'altro è da poco che è
passato all anniversario di questo video
non so se lo sapete che è lasciata
entrare ascanio e scema nomi rosi non
sapete cos'è scema mirosic a avete
presente tutte le canzoni che ipo piane
che ho fatto che ho fatto vedere coi
sottotitoli che sembra che parli in
italiano ecco la bellissima canzone che
ho sentito io non italianizzata non era
che hip hop ma era iraniana
faccio
esce
cosa è lasciato alle spalle
gennaio
maggio è un altro
esce
credo sia per la talmente a memoria che
non ormai non mi fa a me non fa neanche
più effetto cioè per me questa religione
questa per me quando lotto di gennaio io
lascio la porta aperta proprio la porta
spalancata
sperando sempre che entri ascanio è una
ricorrenza che si fa all 8 di gennaio
che è passato da un po e poi ragazzi c'è
stata la mia prima interazione con uno
youtuber molto conosciuto oggi karim
perché io lo seguivo tantissimo giorno
lui aveva fatto delle domande per cui fa
per vestiti poi farvi risponde falli
yotobi risponde non è vero siccome non
sapevo che domanda a farli gli ho
scritto semplicemente sotto nei commenti
questo la seconda la domanda arriva da
the shelf gaming che mi dice sei
ingrassato e che mi richiamano le
magliette con una taglia più piccola
emessa dello stretto ve lo giuro ecco
spero che tu sia contento lo sono ho
sempre adorato la parte in cui star one
perché poi ovviamente la provvista un
miliardo di volte quando per e item
piero fan della serie minchia risposto
io do vi ho sempre adorato la parte dove
lui reagisce e tipo starnutisce senza il
fazzoletto frana non si capisce yo yo
che bella adolescenziale adolescenza e
poi niente ho iniziato a fare video con
i miei amici nichi e luca ho iniziato il
mio canale del gaming soprattutto da
questo video particolare 11 punti 26 già
monetizzava mo primo video ma sembra che
ciao a tutti i ragazzi e qui è niki box
qua fa vj siamo ciechi non mi riconosco
neanche con la voce sinceramente non
sembra neanche io quando parlo se ti che
roba ragazzi di 16 anni e due abbiamo
appena iniziato
abbiamo appena fatto questo canale de
charme gaming appunto perché vogliamo
non sapevo neanche cosa volevamo fare
non so cosa dire nè un video di 11
minuti li dove parlo del nulla del nulla
cosmico e adesso ragazzi con gli altri
scusarmi ma il mondo aveva bisogno di me
quindi ho fatto un change suite il mio
amico ciccio non so per chi non lo
conoscesse è un po strano perché nella
metà dei miei video ha fatto un video
recentemente dove io marco lui e la
ragazza di marco abbiamo fatto la gioco
della bottiglia siccome il vecchio il
video del gioco della bottiglia era
andato così tanto ho deciso di farvi
vedere un po di highlights di quello che
è successo durante il gioco della
bottiglia visto che probabilmente vi
interessa trovate comunque il video
completo del gioco della bottiglia sul
canale di ciccio dello sci descrizione
direi che non potrei desiderare amici
migliori di quelli che obbligo
mancino cerca di infilare un dito del
piede in bocca ci provo e turca
marco quale il lavoro dei sogni che
avresti voluto fare il dj
pensavo paolo di bala setino gli scarti
mischierà una bevanda e poi decina degli
ingredienti
voglio dividere salute corre attorno al
gruppo di amaie come un cane matura di
dubbio un eguale perfetto sviste fatti
di segnali da marco direi sopracciglia
ed arrabbiato convivere 1100 un
pennarello
dubbi che questa cosa lo ispira ma me lo
fa fare
e se le fa bene me le tatu perché
comunque finisca sempre qualcosina temi
a noi che ti stanno male prima di finire
questa roba
però non devi di usa prego ciccio un po
un po un po un po ma che stagione dove
vai
si rifanno a parte come le come si sente
dice basten e bubble sapere cos'è allora
ecco allora ho capito
poi c'è un po di ketchup e poi c'è
dell'aglio è un po di sale tutto
mischiato non è niente di troppo strano
proprio mixato fa schifo io come al
solito ragazzi vi ringrazio per aver
visto il video però vi sia per citare
che ascom è salito subito bisogna c'era
un bel like anche vari social comitato
grande schizzare il mondo ha bisogno di
me quindi io me ne vado
a
[Musica]